Cisco is by no means a household name
but you have probably heard of them as
they're one of the world's biggest
networking companies being valued over
200 billion dollars placing them as
number 64 on the fortune 500 list during
a dot-com bubble they actually become
the world's most valuable company about
over 500 billion dollars so what does
Cisco even do and how did it get so big
make sure stick around till the end to
find out welcome to hari sadhus so all
started in December of 1984 when sandy
Lerner director of computer facilities
at Stanford Graduate School of Business
and her husband Leonard Bozak who's in
charge of the computers in the computer
science department of Stanford
University decided to start a company
that was named Cisco Systems they were
heavily inspired by the Stanford campus
technology I was used in the early 1980s
students and staffs at the campus would
use technology that was all linked
together enabling them to all talk with
one another this function is a multi
protocol Rueter that was called the blue
box blue box new software that was
developed by William eager that was
designed very well this would become key
to Cisco's early success as this
architecture scaled very well in 1985
Bocek and Stanford employee named Kirk
Lougheed started a formal project that's
based on Stanford Network system and
adopted Yeager's code and this became
the foundation of the Cisco IOS but this
clearly did not go well with the
Stanford officials on July 11th of 1986
both the thought would actually be
forced to resign
Stanford even concerned a vacant quit
book complaints against Cisco for theft
of software hardware and intellectual
property but fortunately for Cisco
Sanford did not follow through with that
they actually ended up licensing their
router software and two computer boards
to Cisco in 1987
so obviously cisco was off to a pretty
rough start but they're a small team
would really make things happen so
moving back a little bit their company
name was actually derived from the city
name San Francisco in the earlier Cisco
really insist
on their name being spelled with the
lowercase C but they have since left
that go and their local actually depicts
the Golden Gate Bridge in 1985 they saw
the very first part which was a network
interface card which they sold to
Digital Equipment Corporation but the
following year is when they would come
out with their first blade successful
product this was simply a router but
what made it so special was that it
served multiple network protocols this
batter was so successful that he
required more cash in order to expand
and as a result they turned to
investment in late 1987 the venture
capitalist firm Sequoia Capital would
take control of the company at that time
it seemed like the right thing to do but
this would actually come back to bite
them later just a couple of months after
they came they replaced Bill graves with
John morgridge as president and CEO now
John morgridge is a very capable man and
took the company in the right direction
but he'd not get along well with the
pounds of the company despite this the
company continued to grow in our
February 16 1990 the company went public
on NASDAQ with a market cap of 224
million dollars but unfortunately soon
after in August of 1990 sandy Lerner
would be fired her husband Bo sac would
then resign out of anger and neither of
them would ever get hired back it wasn't
all bad though as they would walk away
from Cisco with the total of 170 million
dollars as for Cisco Systems they were
still doing pretty well but they
completely transitioned from a
family-owned business to a very
corporate business but why was Cisco so
successful in the first place they
weren't the first company to develop and
sell network nodes that is true but
they're the first companies of
commercial routers capable of multiple
network protocols and the classic cpu
architecture in their early devices
really set them apart as well their
devices were very advanced and honker
was rarely an issue as a result
customers didn't have to go out
repeatedly by every generation of Cisco
devices this was not only beneficial for
the consumers but also Cisco Cisco
didn't have to design new designs in the
new products every single year this
really allowed him to focus on their
software and evolve with the rapidly
growing technology they really focused
on issuing frequent software updates
that kept the devices off the date and
their most popular models like the Cisco
2500 would stay in production for almost
a decade
physically unchanged this meant huge
savings for Cisco they didn't have to
focus on hardware and software plus this
made their software really good that's
absolutely all they were working on and
then in the early 1990s they used all of
these savings and put it towards
companies that part companies like
called pornog Grand Junction and other
companies that formed the capital
business unit clearly Cisco was doing
really good as the Internet age world
route Cisco really adapted to the
Internet Protocol during the mid to late
1990s they interest modern access shops
like that AAS 5200 and GSR routers but
just like any other technology company
during this time the dot-com bubble
heavily influenced her growth but Cisco
would benefit from the dot-com bubble
more than any other technology company
in fact by late March of 2000 Cisco
Systems would become the most buried
company in the entire world valued over
five hundred billion dollars but of
course when the.com bubble burst Cisco
Systems experienced a significant
decline just like every other technology
company like Dell and Oracle but none of
those other companies had reached the
heights at Cisco had reached and as a
result they weren't hurt as deeply and
these unfortunate circumstances
Fransisco made it the perfect
opportunity for competitors to jump in
the biggest competitor Juniper Networks
were very determined to find a new way
to pass the IP and mpls packets they
released her first part a couple of
years ago in 1999 but this is when they
would really grow in fact they were chip
away Cisco's market share and go to hold
30 percent Cisco retaliated very quickly
by developing faster processing cards
and GSR routers they also developed 86
which are simply application-specific
integrated circuits you have probably
heard about them they were especially
with Bitcoin and in theory mining just
last year and in 2004 they started
migration into a new high log platform
called CSR - one they also got a new
software architecture called iOS that XR
all of these changes allow a Cisco start
to bounce back from the dot-com bubble
and they were start to grow once again
in 2006 they would make a terrible
mistake of trying to become a household
company they start off this efforts by
sharing their name from Cisco Systems -
Cisco they would also put a lot of money
and effort into promoting links these
products and their future consumer
prices as well at the same time they
were also really trying to focus on the
traditional business as well while all
of this was going on they were also
trying to expand internationally growing
into new markets for example they tried
to build a presence in India by
establishing a global center of the ease
in Bangalore for 1 billion dollars on
top of all of this they're trying to
acquire their way to new markets as well
but here's the thing there's only so
many things that you can do at the same
time and be successful at all of them
and Cisco trying to do all of these at
the same time was a recipe for disaster
despite all of these efforts their
competitors were gaining ground very
quickly they had domestic competition
for copies like Juniper Networks and
they also had international competition
from companies like Huawei which have
recently been very popular in the news
all of these would lead to very
disappointing profits for Cisco in 2011
and they would decide to cut their
spending by 1 billion dollars per year
and how exactly did they accomplish this
well mainly by cutting employees they
cut 3,000 straight off the bat and
thousands more would be offered early
retirement packages and things of that
sort what everything was said and done
10,000 jobs are eliminated eliminating
14 percent of their workforce Cisco was
clearly in a very bad place in 2013
Cisco would sell links east of Belkin
international and this will interchange
from consumer side back onto network
side but years of missteps continue to
have devastating consequences
in 2013 they had to cut 4,000 more dogs
and then again in 2014 they cut 6,000
more jobs but things would really start
to turn around as John Chambers stepped
down as CEO he will be replaced by chuck
Robbins and this would really revitalize
the company it's not that John Chambers
is unqualified excuse to you for 20
years and it's not like Chuck Robbins
can bring an outside perspective as he
had been at that company for the past 17
years but nonetheless this fleet did
help the company after they were took
the focus on the cloud-based networking
and a cloud-based networking is really
what would take the company out of the
ditch they sold consumer companies like
Technicolor sa for six hundred million
dollars and invest in newer startups
like Bello cloud and in February of 2017
they would launch our own cloud-based
secure Internet gateway called Cisco
umbrella this would provide safe access
to the Internet for users who don't use
corporate networks or BP ins to connect
to remote data centers and after all of
these changes that revenue has really
started to grow once again in my opinion
they were simply just spread too thin
and just need to focus on what they were
best on to find success once again and
just last year they bought an AI driven
business intelligent company called a
company for 270 million dollars and
today you're doing better than ever
before Cisco is a copy that started very
shaky beginnings but became a network
giant after a dot-com bubble and rising
competition they did have a lot of
trouble as their own focus and to spread
out but after downsizing and selling off
their consumer related businesses and
really focusing on cloud-based
networking cisco has really been able to
grow into networked giant once again and
at this rate no Peter dot-com highs in
just a couple of years so while Cisco
may not be a household name they have
truly revolutionized networking and I
really found a lot of success in what
they do best but that's all I have for
you guys on Cisco make sure you comment
down below what company you would like
me to cover next also if you guys liked
this video
you drop a like and consider subscribing
if you like see more videos just like
this one
Brenda then I'm Laurie I'll see you guys
on the next one
[Music]